hey guys before we get started i just
wanted to let you know about my tour
date september 16th through the 18th
i'll be in phoenix september 30th
through october 2nd i'm in
india helium i'll be out on the road uh
doing some dates with tom segura right
now october 8th
and 9th in vegas i am headlining the
brea
improv on october 28th all right we are
adding more dates
uh also want to let you know ringtones
of my laugh are now available you can go
to itunes
search my name scroll down to ringtones
and
get them there or you can go to my
website alright
tickets for all my shows and information
for the ringtones can be found on
ryanstickler.com
this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by stamps.com
freshly manscaped and purple more on
that later
let's get into the do the honeydew
with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here
doing it in the night pants studios i am
ryan sickler ryan sickler on all social
media ryan sickler.com
please subscribe to the youtube channel
and if you gotta have more do subscribe
to the patreon community it's five bucks
a month there's no tears no nothing you
get the full
show an hour long usually i do with uh
with y'all
um and we're hearing some wild [ __ ] out
there all right so if you or anyone you
know has that story it's got to be heard
please submit it to honeydewpodcast
gmail.com and hopefully we get to do a
story for you
hit up that merch store keep supporting
those night pants nation we're going to
get some live shows going when this [ __ ]
gets back to normal do a night pants
nation tour
i'll wear night pants you wear night
pants you don't have them come out we'll
buy some [ __ ] night pants sell the
[ __ ] out of some light pants with you
guys build up the nation
all right you know we record here at
santa monica music center uh
so we're working on a podcast right now
with otta outreach through the arts the
at-risk youth kids i've been telling you
about with the santa monica police
department they got a badass little
podcast we're building here
can't wait to get that out there for
them and i just love promoting it every
week so
that's what i'm doing i'm teaching these
kids how to do a podcast and they are
crushing it right now all right if
you're uh new to the show here welcome
what we do over here is we highlight the
low lights it's a beautiful [ __ ] show we
are
shining light on that darkness and these
are the story tell
the stories behind the storytellers and
today's storyteller i am
very excited to finally get on this show
ladies and gentlemen kyle kane y'all
welcome to the honeydew brother
man we already we're starting i'm like
just rolling
just roll man you've been saying the
whole time i got a year
so excited to have a year of dumb [ __ ]
going on before we get into it plug
everything please
social media podcasts books albums
whatever show canadian
on the internet i got a podcast called
the boogie monster
it was supposed to be about ghosts but
it's not anymore
it's just me and my buddy dave it's
like i don't know people are like you
don't talk about bigfoot how many
episodes you think about bigfoot he's
[ __ ] maybe he's real and then that's
it and then we just talk about food
but you know kyle conan and then you
find me and i'll tell you about the
stuff
all right i get i don't i don't feel
good shame i'm talking about shame i
feel shameful plugging stuff
dude i hear you on that you said earlier
you have a buffet
of shame you could go yeah i don't have
any like deep dives
i was watching the clips of the show to
get ready i'm like
there's no getting ready dude you don't
need me on this show man like i was like
because i'm like i don't know i don't
even know some of the people but i'm
like i don't know if that's a comedian
but i'm not it's not like i know every
comedian let's click on
whoever this is like and then when i was
eight years old my veins clapped from
heroin use
like what the [ __ ] dude what
when i was eight i was heartbroken
because my friend didn't want to play
pretend spaceship in the yard anymore
they had people out here like suck and
dick to pay for food
for their younger siblings i'm like why
am i on the show i don't deserve to be
on the show
this is for much more outlandish stories
than mine
[Laughter]
thank you for the greatest [ __ ] promo
of the show we've had right there
because we're cutting that i got nothing
on these sons of [ __ ] i got
nothing on them then i thought i did i
look at my stand up i'm like ooh man
canadian really puts it out there oh we
really appreciate his honesty
when i read your list i was like i'll
talk to him
[Laughter]
uh you make me feel good dude so let's
talk about
i knew one guy who died but he was like
a friend but not a close friend i'm like
i don't want to exploit that
it was sad but not like the worst well
i'll let you talk about whatever you
want to talk about but
let me then i or i can ask you questions
or we can do both because what
start with where you're from and what
just growing up was like for you let's
just start there because i don't know
where are you originally from
i'm from a town called addison illinois
okay which is like 20 miles west of
chicago
and uh grew up and uh yeah not honeydew
material
just two parents who were loving and
they were together
yeah they were together the whole time
yeah uh
you know like as a comedian you could
tell people trying to drum but
uh you know my dad was laid off yeah
laid off yeah that's the worst
but then he got another job and uh so
it's actually kind of worked out right
you're gonna do an hour about a year
transition
i didn't even notice we you know my
parents didn't raise me uh materialistic
so i didn't really notice i was not
playing with dirt i didn't care about
toys
um but yeah i grew up there and uh
probably for too long stayed until i was
20 lived at home until i was 26.
why because probably
my mom uh was is overbearing and this is
the thing too they're
they're both still alive and watch all
this [ __ ] so i still i'm like yeah you
gotta be careful
nice things because yeah i still love
truth they're great
but every time i was like were you in
college like community college
i was in three colleges went to college
for seven and a half
years because i never had any opposing
force
i never had a reason to become an adult
i see i went to a community college and
i was a good student i was like honor
student
smart uh not quite the very top of the
class but up there 3.0
b straight b's oh no i was like way up
there oh sorry you better i i was way up
there i mean well
i don't mean to compare myself
intellectually let's say yeah okay
yeah intellectually we'll say yeah
28 on the acts that should be that
should have been at least a partial
did you ever see i never did man i i'm
telling you
i scored horribly on the i did it twice
too i
i think i got i'm trying to find if
anyone out there does know i would love
a link to dig up my old sat scores i've
been looking
i really think i got a 870 the first
time or an 880 and then the next time i
got 890. it was 10 more points i was
like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] what do they go to i don't
even know what they're doing i mean a
thousand
i feel like you get 800 for signing your
[ __ ] name on the thing you know
yeah i was not stellar a test taker at
all
because we had we had like yeah ours
were like the iowa standard testing it
was a joke
like iowa standard testing then you go
to iowa and you're like this shouldn't
be where we based standardized tests off
of
and then we had a cts which apparently
nobody else knows what those are
no we had the you could take one or the
other oh yeah you could take sats right
and they were scored differently yeah
yeah and it was like 31 i think was the
highest i got a 28.
damn and like and again like i feel now
that we're talking i do feel bad i think
my mom
really tried her best to line me up
for success somehow but why are you not
leaving why are you not leaving because
you're comfortable at home are you
paying rent or no
kicking in i was going to say first off
the act she made me take a prep course
for it
so i'm pro that's probably why i got a
high a score as i did um
but then i stayed there and i was like i
was having fun man
like i was one of those people that was
raised
that you're like it's like a very 40
year old virgin type thing where you're
so respectful of women you're scared of
them
so unless a woman more or less is like
um if a woman was like i'm gonna [ __ ]
you
you're never gonna have sex which is
what happened when i was 21 years old
and i lost my virginity to a stripper
did you yeah and she put her finger the
longest one up my ass
and so there's a story that's a thing
but that's nothing compared to what else
has been on the show
you don't even know that because we this
this finger up the ass might be the
literal
she was talking about some [ __ ] we dig
in she related she was tall
all right so hold on let's go back let's
go back because creature hands
um are you at a strip club in town like
a lo is this a local
club you're freaking out let's leave i
love foreplay
so i want to answer your other question
so i think my mom had gotten me
like tonight like you respect women so i
just never dated like nobody ever dated
we
everybody was like friends and my sister
is two years younger than me
and like her group of friends and our
group of friends everybody's pals
and then everybody didn't want to [ __ ]
it up with trying to hook up it's maybe
there's something in the water in
addison that made kids less horny i
don't know
but there was no really no teen
pregnancy
nobody's trying to hump i don't know if
it's like catholic guilt but usually
catholicism would like pressurize kids
to go the other way
but uh we all kind of like we're pretty
respectful of each other at least that
that was my impression of it if somebody
else has a different story i i
didn't hear it um and then yeah we were
just like
i had a band i was playing punk bands
and my mom
would like what did you play i played
guitar okay i played drums too
pl i attempted these things but again
you know it's punk rock it's not like
skill
but then we practice at at my folks
basement and that's i
i feel bad because i know i've done
jokes about these things in the past so
i don't want to just like throw punch
lines at you
but like but it really was like i'm
trying to be punk
rock like [ __ ] yeah i'm gonna get a
tattoo i got a tattoo at 18. i lost my
virginity at 21.
i had tattoos by then i'm like i'm a
rebel and then my mom's like i'm making
chili dip for everybody it's like [ __ ]
no
don't don't stop making chili dip
it's not punk rock but also we need the
basement on tuesdays and thursdays
because we got a show coming up it's a
move bridge to wednesdays
yeah yes bingo nights were thursdays was
good my dad worked midnight and so he
was he was out of the house by 7 p.m
and so it was fine and then she'd get
mad like they drank all the pepsi i'm
like stop by
stop letting them have the pepsi don't
put peps in the house let them have
all the pepsi then yell at me yell at
them they're the ones drinking it
because
the whole party like everybody would
hang out at the house and she remember
that you were that house yeah it was
that house but it was like
it was still pretty responsible it
wasn't like some sort of derelict house
it was like my mom hung out my mom loved
company and loved
yeah it was kid it was a kid-friendly
house yeah but this was kids
and then until early 20s and it was you
know
people drank inside my mom smokes
so people could smoke cigarettes inside
weed was outside she knew what's going
on she's not in front of her kind of
thing
it never got really harder than that
there was like we did have a big ecstasy
phase
and that was weird because like to do
ecstasy and try and be punk rock
i remember how so no no no no this is uh
no because like punk rock's like oh you
drink and [ __ ] it even weed you're like
hippie [ __ ] man drink [ __ ] punk rock
stuff and then we all did ecstasy
at a friend's house and first i remember
my buddy walking in
and we were like like had like a human
centipede of back rubs going on
we're just just rocking wait what was
your name your band name
we were the grand marquis and we tried
to pluralize it
the grand marquis because two of us
drove grand marquis the car
but we didn't know how to pluralize it
because there's a french word that ended
in s
so to grab our keys yeah we just spelled
it the grand marquis and then people
like you're the grand marquis it's like
it's the grand marquis but uh we don't
we pronounce it as a plural and we just
couldn't that's we couldn't figure out
how we wanted to spell it so we never
made merch
uh but yeah my buddy walked in we were
just all neck rubbing and he just went
what the [ __ ] i guess this looks kind of
weird
and then we all we're like just having
this emotional bonding experience on
ecstasy
and we're all like laying on like
somebody's parents deck
and all our chain wallets got stuck in
those slats
we all we all tried to get up but we
were all stuck we had to
do our chain wallets to get off the deck
that was so stupid man anything like
that
all of you and it's like and like the
next day you're like really
don't tell anybody we're getting into
ecstasy because even though it's the
most loving drug
like it makes you so appreciative we're
just so ashamed and we felt like we
betrayed our punk rock roots by doing it
oh that's great but so yeah
i was doing that and i was playing music
and i i was now are the other guys in
the band dating or are these all guys in
your circle too or they
are anyone coming in everybody was all
in the sounds and that's why it was fun
because we were like we were friends we
had i think we had more fun at practice
than we did book and shows
yeah cause like oh we gonna move this
stuff we have to drag drums upstairs it
sucks
so we did that i went to college for a
year
i went to community college for a year
because i'm like i don't want to leave
and i
early on i think early on i got set on
this
like this question everything maybe it
was punk rock i'd be like like the
question
how things are supposed to be just with
life in general just seeing
either well go to college you go to
college
you go to college yeah like community
college i still went and got my degree
and to this day
the only reason i got it is because
that's what i thought we were supposed
to do
like i right at this point the way
college is i don't know how things are
going to change
my daughter's six i don't think i would
push her or
to push her into college if she doesn't
want to go i don't know that it's the
best choice these days
hopefully there's some sort of form they
change what they [ __ ] teach you
yeah they're not you're changing that
too
um yeah i right away i was like i don't
know what i want to do
i'm 18 and you want me to pay
how much to sort it out right for a
piece of paper
nah man i'm gonna go to this community
college and
everybody was having fun there it was
the best time and you did think you were
still
inching towards 13th grade oh yeah yeah
yeah
college of dupage that was like
everybody had that rumor like they're
going to make it for your school
yeah stick around but this is like a big
like people traveled from out of the
area to like
be on the sports teams for the community
college it was like a reputable school
but i did that for a year i'm like well
this is how much fun community college
is i'm going to go
to university illinois chicago it's the
only i left home and i didn't even make
it a semester
you went to the big university uh not
well it was like uh college
the university of illinois not the not
the big one and not the sports one the
one in chicago
and i was there for two months [ __ ]
got arrested
arrested yeah yeah here we go huh
well for what oh anyone just glanced
through
believe me if i was sat here and taught
that but you ever been arrested i would
have
definitely because don't watch jason
ellis interview and then think this is
going to
blow your mind there's only one jason
ellis dude guys
i made her i made a buttercup out of my
ball sack and girls drink piss out of it
i'm like
i wouldn't tell that story that story i
wouldn't that's a story i wouldn't tell
i would like be like nah i'm gonna
that one's i'm keeping put the [ __ ]
nails in the pine
and that's where that story's coming
with me tuck that one in my [ __ ] suit
pocket
at my funeral
no we got me and my buddy greg the the
dude who's in my band
uh that's who i was roommates with and
we just it's so dumb we just went
it was halloween and uh
so all along the uh like
the like where people lived off campus
was still wasn't a great area but like
there's halloween parties so it wasn't
like college town type stuff but it was
still packed in apartments and
brownstones and stuff
and so we're just bouncing around from
halloween to party to halloween party
and uh i don't think we had costumes on
and we just we're bored and we're just
kind of following groups of people at
parties and
eventually he's like hey man we ought to
paper towels i'm like yeah he's like
he just starts taking [ __ ] that we
needed for the dorm room from these
parties like no not
no high money items yeah like utensils
and [ __ ]
some nuts yeah necessity like yeah
mustard
musty yeah yeah just not like oh we
don't oh we don't have relish
it's a rush hot dog night take some
relic
look at this look at this apartment they
can get they can get new relish
they got mommy daddy relish we don't
have mommy daddy rollers you take that
relish
so he's packing all this in and
all of a sudden like and i'm just egging
him on i'm like go about some of this
and eventually he sees like a sombrero
so now he's got a sombrero on
coat filled with stuff and we go to
leave the party
and this girl goes hey that's my
sombrero
a white girl claiming sombrero and uh
that's my sombrero you can't take that
and it's like oh i'm sorry puts it down
i just go take something else
and there's like you know how college uh
apartments are decorated some
thrift store mirror with like a sailboat
print on it but big but like big
and uh he just looks and he goes click
and takes it off the wall i'm like well
that's ridiculous if the sombrero
got you busted there's no way we'll get
out with this thing
and uh he he's got it under his arm and
we get to the door
he's walking through the party with this
yeah and then the same great we
struggling with the door and the same
girl comes up i'm like here we go she's
like sometimes it sticks
and she just opens the door for us and
lets us out with her sombrero yeah
yeah you can even roll one of your ours
[ __ ] that's not you never
no that's my sombrero like think you can
claim ownership but i'm guessing you
didn't buy this
sometimes it stinks but it lets you
right out
we ran down the stairs i think it was
off loomis it was off loomis street
uh like west of the college and uh
ran down off loomis street we're also to
this day uh
a plaster sculpture of my penis uh is
still somewhere in the dirt and it also
has a little superman cape on it is that
right
i'll tell that story next i i haven't
talked to anybody in a year but it's so
fun
to do okay so we run out and we're just
like i'm like right i'm like
man i can't believe you stole that
mirror and right there the cops were
there to bust up the party
so their lights go on because they see
people running
and it's you know it's blue and red so
my buddy tosses the mirror and it breaks
i'm like well that's symbolic yeah right
and i'm like man i can't believe we're
getting busted for stealing that mirror
because we're just here freeze
and they were there to just break up
parties you know neighbors called
complaints on him stuff
but we got busted and the party got
busted
so the whole party was getting you know
led out of that building well we're
getting frisked
on the cop car and he's just got like
napkins
and plastic forks and [ __ ] just
falling out of his coat and blowing down
the street and the cops like what the
[ __ ] is this
and so we so we went to jail we went to
the drunk tank for the night because the
girl's like yeah him like
had us arrested and um and we thought it
was cool
punk rally like and you know you go to
like uh jail and they take your
shoelaces and your belt and everything
and we're like scratching our names
in the bench
i mean i'm not on the pills for it but i
got to make friends in here
and we were lucky we got our own cell so
we had like and again
[ __ ] happened but in the best scenario
because so we're just and we're still
drunks we're like that man
this is the street cred we need [ __ ]
that chili dip mom and now i'm in jail
now this is gonna this is gonna make
liner notes
for the album if we ever get it out and
um
they let us out so we kind of slept
there so we didn't get in the big drunk
tank
um and i'm sure at that like chicago
cops seeing two idiot college kids are
just like [ __ ]
fine like we're not gonna give you the
worst we can give you
and um so we wake up they give us like
the bologna sandwich which is just
horrible
and like now we're hungover waking up
and jay like
what this is like now the shame sets in
of like oh we we just have parents that
we love and they're gonna be sad when
they find out about this
and they'll find out because we're
guilty and we'll tell them
uh so they let me out first i can't
figure out
at this point twenty nineteen nineteen
yeah
and it was nineteen yeah uh i
like i this sandwich was so bad and i
was so hungover but i didn't want to
like throw it on the ground cause i'm
like i'm not getting i don't get busted
for literally i
tucked it in a bush i had my bag with
all my stuff in it with my shoelaces and
my belt
i get back to campus and then i'm in
line in the cafeteria
and they've got like the the taco bell
and stuff in the cafeteria line
in in the campus as i'm starting to kind
of feel cool like i got my chicago
police department back i'm like ask me
what happened
babes huh bad boy's back bad boy's back
wild nice wild night ask him about it
and uh so i'm in line at taco bell and
the dude working at the taco bell
sees my bag and i didn't know that there
was a sexual assault on a campus the
night before
so i'm walking around with chicago
chicago police department bag
like and so i'm just trying to get my
chalupas or whatever all hung over and
this dude making them just goes
oh you're the dude that raped that chick
and i was like oh my god no
and then everybody looks at me like no
and i just run now i got a bag of taco
bell bag of shoelaces
and i just locked myself in my dorm room
yeah
like i like every effort towards being
cool just backfired
so bad would just backfired so much in
my life
i felt horrible
we went over the girl's house i think we
bought i think we brought him flowers
i think we're like please don't press
charges
we went to court they never showed up so
the charges got dropped
oh my god that is all yeah and then i
was up
and then so i dropped out of that not
long after that i dropped out of context
me out of there i forgot there was
homework to do
my buddy was going to columbia college
in chicago which would eventually be my
third and final college that i went to
but he was taking an art class and he's
like we got to do sculpture he's like
hey man what if i made a sculpture your
dick
i got nothing to brag about and cold
plaster isn't gonna make it prettier
but i was like yeah it'd be kind of
hilarious but didn't realize i just had
to go to the school to do it and i'm
just like in a studio
where like it's not just you and your
buddy no i'm just like at his class
and like yeah we'll just go i thought
you guys were doing this in like his
apartment oh he's like we'll just go to
the supply closet
he's got like a little box made with
plaster in it
and it was so cold in it are you trying
to are you trying to get hard
or are you just putting it in no i no
there's no i'm like you weren't trying
to go for it
no because i think i want to be
remembered happy you know what i mean no
because i would
what if you had your your best effort
and people made fun of it
no matter what your best effort is
someone is going you don't think
someone's going to [ __ ] on this show
i will lean towards like given how these
things have worked out when i've tried
to be cool or look good or macho fair
enough
i've learned my lesson just lean into
ridiculous
like this [ __ ] happened to me yesterday
i
i you know
last night personal maintenance beat off
and then got the email it says oh we
have access to your webcam
give us bitcoin which is a spam but i
got it like right after
like the timing was impeccable and after
the
i just had a week i already had cops
pull me out of my sister's house with
their guns out last sunday
i had to dig my van out of the desert i
told you i just talked about this week
i don't have to do we have to talk about
my childhood tell me about what happened
the last seven days
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor stamps.com the
summer is showing
welcoming signs of a more normal life
ahead and finally
you can get back to enjoying life's
little pleasures like smiling at your
neighbor or seeing a movie and going to
the post office all right some
parts of normal life aren't so great but
with stamps.com you can skip trips to
the post office
and save on postage mail and ship
anytime
anywhere right from your computer you
can send letters
you can ship packages and pay less a lot
less
with discounted rates from usps and
ups shout out to ups baltimore hub
primary one joe avenue stamps.com saves
businesses
thousands of hours and tons of money
every year stamps.com is a no-brainer
saving nearly 1 million small business
owners like you
time and money and they offer deals you
can't get anywhere else like up to 40
percent off of
usps and up to 66 off of
ups shipping rates and with their switch
and save feature you can quickly compare
carriers
to find the best rates every time
stop wasting time going to the post
office and go to stamps.com instead
there's no risk
and with my promo code honeydew you get
a special offer that includes a
four-week trial
and free postage and a digital scale
there's no long-term commitments or
contracts so just go to stamps.com you
click on the mic
at the top of the home page and type in
honeydew that's stamps.com
promo code honeydew stamps.com never go
to the post office again
our next sponsor is freshly are you
stressed are you tired or
you just don't feel like cooking food
that's fast doesn't have to be
fast food freshly offers quality meals
without the hard work of prepping
cooking and cleaning freshly offered
chef made nutrient packed delicious
meals
delivered fresh to your door there's no
cooking required
grocery shopping and cooking can be a
pain especially right now
and with freshly you don't have to your
meals arrive cooked
and they're fresh every week so you can
keep your fridge stocked
and skip the trip to the store ordering
is easy you visit freshly.com
you can choose from over 30 delicious
satisfying better for you meals
like steak peppercorn sausage baked
penne or their chicken pesto bowl which
i really like
freshly can fit your lifestyle with a
variety of plans and meals to pick from
that work for your dietary needs
preferences taste and family size and
now
my listeners can try freshly for just
6.16 a meal all right that's cheaper
than fast food and this is so much
healthier for you i love having it
in the fridge at home when i come home
late from a show or a long day or
something i don't stop and grab fast
food i hit my freshlies up all right
so stop searching the internet for
healthy food near me every night and
start living life freshly
your meals are always delivered fresh
never frozen and ready to heat and enjoy
in just three minutes with new meals
added each week
freshly brings the convenience of chef
may nutritionist design
classics right to your kitchen that's
freshly.com
honeydew for forty dollars off your
first two orders right now
freshly's offering our listeners forty
dollars off your first two orders
when you go to freshly.com slash
honeydew you gotta try it out stop
stressing about dinner go to freshly.com
honeydew for 40 off your first two
orders
now let's get back to the duke let's get
back to your dick and plaster in front
of a class right now can we jump back
okay so it's in there i'm like
this is going to be silly my buddy's
real funny too
cause i mean what's your plan he's like
cause he's taking these art classes but
again we're all in college because we
think we have to be but nobody's taking
it seriously
so he's like oh i'm gonna draw a face on
the head and put a little superman cape
on it and i'm like all right that's
hilarious
so they like he gets it they're trying
to break the plaster off
from around like where the mold is
poured in and even the teacher was like
where is it i'm like all right i don't
need that
i'm giving myself to art i'm being brave
the teacher was fine with this it wasn't
like a
it's an art school that you did not need
a high school diploma to get into
so their bar was real low okay and so he
did it it was like in a little cabinet
there just like
little little sad balls in a little tiny
peen
but the cape the superman cape that he
put on it was funny
but then we were at some other party by
uic one night he's like i brought this
back
like i don't want it and i threw it
through a window so that's in an empty
line
yeah it's an empty lot off loomis
somewhere
if they haven't put condos over there's
some construction worker
some archaeologist in 500 years
analyzing the roots of gentrification is
gonna find that
in the west loop
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all right you have you said quite a few
things we got
pulled out of your sister's house we
have uh oh let's go back all right we're
going chronologically here
your dick's literally in the dirt now
yeah let's talk about it
let's talk about this virginity story
how do you not date at all like i want
to give you fresh stories yeah please
i've told you i i've no i i never had
girlfriends i never so you didn't even
have a girlfriend before you lost your
virginity
no no really no i think i had
data it it str the idea of like trying
to meet a girl
stressed me out so much it would have
had to have been outside your circle too
had been outside the circle because
nobody wanted to jeopardize friendships
or make things
at least i did not and uh any time i
went out
i had more fun i didn't have the kind of
group of friends it was like yeah we're
gonna go and meet chicks like
no we're gonna go out to have the best
time like i had so much
fun and also i thought i was preserving
that
fun by not trying to
date it i looked at it like a career or
something like you do this later like i
wasn't
and part of me i just felt like a loser
too because i'm like i live at home like
i don't have much to offer you know
i remember like you know you meet girls
out like let's go back to your place
wow we can't really do that
because it's uh 25 miles away
and my mom's still up she gets home from
bingo and hangs out for a while
the basement's hers yeah hangs out
watching hgtv for a while
that shit's on right now on three
different tvs on the same channel in my
house
i go back home and it's like being in a
stadium when they make an announcement
because everything's on like a half
second delay
but it's the same thing on every tv it's
like why can't you appreciate
silence what's wrong with you people
just sit and jo you live in the suburbs
there's birds and [ __ ]
enjoy that anyway so
at this point in my super cool
what at the time i thought was cool jobs
in a
like a working class i really thought i
was like this
mike ness bruce springsteen hybrid
blue collar punk rock and i was just a
[ __ ] loser
i just i delivered pizzas and worked at
a gas station
but because i rolled the sleeves up on
my gas station
uniform i was like i'm a bad boy
uh i didn't even work i didn't fix the
cars i was a cashier
my hands were clean i cleaned i didn't
have to walk
the only guy at the gas station yeah i
had to clean the toilets
i did i didn't have to clean the toilets
that was my job was cleaning
gas station bathrooms and so
i was i was in there and they uh this
gal came in
and just real talk like i'm five eight
i'm not
i'm not big but she's she i probably
six feet plus and uh
like a like you know a lanky gal
and it was night shift she's like i knew
any shoe stores open
it was like 9 30 at night i'm like the
[ __ ] shoes at 9 30 at night
and i let her use the i'm like looking
through the phone book for she didn't
tell me why she needed shoes
and i let her use the phone because it's
like a pre
or just right around where not everybody
had a cell phone kind of days
because yeah this had to be like 97 or
so
late 90s and uh like yeah
i don't know i don't need shoes i don't
need normal shoe store or something
she's like all right well thanks for
your help take a work down at uh
all strip club down the street
she's like come in i'll give you a free
dance i'm like oh well
all right sleeves are working bro yeah
i'm like sleeves
of course naturally
oh bad boy rides again once again
once again i still had not learned a
lesson about leaning into this [ __ ]
and also uh being horny virgins horny
old virgins i'd say that's an old virgin
this one 21 21 21 yeah it's up there
yeah that's an old virgin i called my
other buddy he was an old virgin i'm
like man you're not gonna believe what
happened
we go to the strip club i can get a free
dance
like that's the limit i thought this
night was going to go
and had you ever at that time been to a
stripper oh yeah no we were going to
strip clubs
the one we were going to we had already
been to and they were fun because we
used to like put play like joke songs
and they would dance to them for us
because like we'd go on a tuesday and
they're bored and we'd
spend what little money we had and like
we were fun too
that's the thing we weren't creeps as
much as we wanted to see naked ladies
we also wanted like fun was the priority
yeah sort of like you know well will you
dance the pacman fever and like yeah
well that's [ __ ] pac-man fever we
think you're [ __ ]
you know like we're like we're gonna
have fun we're gonna have fun we are fun
people
so my buddy and i went and i remember
god damn the efforts to be cool
first off let me ask you this real quick
how long between the offer
and you guys going like that i think i
was off of work at 10
and you went that long oh yeah yeah no
i'm like i'm not letting this thing dry
up i'm not letting this offer dry up
this coupon this coupon shall not expire
so we go and our routine's like all
right
beers are already going to be expensive
so we're going to drink in the car and
you know like
you know how real rock and rollers real
hardcore rock and rollers
always like to split a half pint of
captain morgan's spiced rum
because that's the most rock and roll
drink we could stomach at the time oh
god man like you think like whiskey or
something like no spiced rum
spice spiced rum in somebody's mom's
jetta
so we're we're sitting out there doing
that
and i remembered i remember distinctly
my buddy laughing at me because we were
listening to the misfits
and i didn't know i was singing along to
the song
skulls but i didn't know the lyric was
skulls and i thought he was singing i
want your touch
so i was like i want your touch
i need your touch
larson and bill burris the first live
one of the that
version i think he did that song he did
skulls
he's got a good voice yeah he's
deceptively a good yeah he could he you
know and he's shimmy's too yeah yeah any
[ __ ]
up there [ __ ] giving it mm-hmm well
i'm saying this this is the same dude
who made the the like dick superman
that i went with got it yeah what kind
of brothers in arms at this point yeah
yeah you are and uh he's like what are
you singing
i'm like i want your touch he's like
it's skull
it's the misfits the [ __ ] does he want
to touch
and i'm like i thought it was like a
like a devil touch it'd be like a double
yeah it'd be like a demonic tug you'd
touch somebody to turn to a zombie or
something
but i remember that i remember that
moment i remember going inside
and then the gal being like oh you're
here and uh
this these details i have
told this i wrote this story when i did
get to my third college and was taking
creative writing
and i was like well let's put this story
out there and like this is a good story
i'm like i wish it wasn't
she uh her stage name was crystal which
was ironic because she was not fragile
in the least
um she danced
she danced to this song do you know the
band jackal
i do remember jackal they didn't have
like a chainsaw in one of their songs a
lumberjack
there's a song called the lumberjack i'm
right here with you
where instead of a guitar solo it's a
chainsaw
that's what she danced to so this is
definitely a white girl
[Laughter]
white girl but with lip liner remember
the lipstick of course of course
remember like like the puerto rican
trend that like everybody did for a
while that
didn't look good and uh
she did that she had a lot of dragon
tattoos
uh just randomly like like like like she
kept going back
trying to get a better one or something
how old would you say
would you say she was i didn't have a
good gauge i i bet she was
late mid mid late 20s
but she's like oh you showed up i'm like
yeah yeah hey
and did like okay took me in the back
room with a private dance and like i
know the rules i know
nope no touching sit on them no touching
your hands i'm not touching nothing
and she's making she's grabbing my hands
i'm like but there's no i'm like moving
them i'm like these guys
will beat me up yeah i've been in that
situation where a girl put my hands on
her and they came back and i was like
bro and she had to say no i did this and
i was like
there and no you know their necks are
like this i'm like i'm not
your titties are not worth my asking and
it's not like it's an above-board
business
where it's like yeah but we want to beat
them up anyway yeah right yeah
but weird enough the one security guard
at this
place we would go to would come by like
because
again we were fun and the bass player
who i got arrested with before we were
all there one time
and the security guard would just come
up behind us and go
kids kids gonorrhea kids and just point
to
all this jefferson like come on man what
are you doing ruining it for you
he was being silly and then
the bass player who i got him and the
security guard just went and saw
titanic together one day what the two
dudes
and i that replaces this
i i understand that these details make
it sound unbelievable
but that like i'm a better storyteller
than that if i wanted to add to the
story to make it spicier i would say
like
that rum oh then yeah yeah i i'll
captain morgan's
[ __ ] the right way i can tell a story
that's why it's a fun detail
because it makes no sense yeah it was
all hanging out
we should be buddies yeah yeah we did
hang out they got along what'd you guys
do we wouldn't saw titanic
the [ __ ] hey man live your life
so anyway this girl goes um
uh you you're gonna come with me tonight
and she tells you yeah well and that's i
told you the only way i'm going to lose
my virginity as a woman
what you said i'm gonna i'm gonna do
this to you like you gotta be invited in
like a vampire so there's no question
that this is in her ballpark i am not
pressuring anybody i am not making
someone else make i'll make the mistake
i am here to be the journalist of
bad choices like that was where the
comedy was starting
even before as a stand-up was like all
right i'll go out there and report back
yeah it'll be i'll be the embedded
journalist i can't tell you how many
times i've said yes for the story
yeah for the story i can't do it anymore
i've done it enough you see comics that
are like 50 and still like we got to say
yes like now you know
the dog you got a family you let the
young
let the young kids get their get their
chops but so
we i told my buddy i'm like she's she
just said
she can't take me from here cuz like you
know obviously
what she does for a living but she's
gonna pick me up at a gas station
over at grand and manheim so you got to
drop me off there like oh boy
so they close down i go my buddy takes
me over to the gas station and wait
there
she drives up black and red camaro i'm
almost gonna ask
i'm kind of nice camaro bro that's yeah
that is late 80s style too not that not
that rounded one t-tops
yeah i don't think it was t-tops
honestly the details started to get real
hazy
because now it was like oh i'm
now i know what's gonna happen and i get
in the car with her and i'm so you're
you're the person who's about to take
your virginity pulled up
pick you up in a camaro this serpent the
drive-through this
serpent came in a black and red camaro
[Music]
get in loser we're taking your virginity
and i get in and i'm like quiet cause
i'm like oh this is it
this this it's happening that's gonna
happen
we're driving and i finally just have to
admit like i didn't know how to i'm like
i'm a virgin and she just goes
not for long and i was like i love this
i
love christmas and then at that point at
that point i was like
because you think you're looking to be
the sexual bad boy you're like i'm not i
always wanted to be nice
oh no i want it the other way i wanted
this to be a mistake when i'm a junior
with a girl as a virgin and we're both
awkward i want that
why didn't i do that why didn't i do
this from the beans
to the pros i'm 21 drunk on spiced rum
and i'm about to get [ __ ] wrecked
that's what's about to happen
so we go we get out to joliet oh she's
like we can't go to my house
i'll have a drive are you guys forever
as far as i was concerned
you figure figure uh where i was that
was like
granted manhattan figure oh hair out to
joliet so
do you have 45 minutes are you
[ __ ] she was ready are you
is there any part of you though that's
like yes finally
like is there any part of you that's
obviously you're still going there was a
little
there's a little bit
but as soon as she's when i was like i'm
a virgin and i was kind of hoping for
oh well hey let's make this a nice
one then they are like yeah i got you
she thought like oh well i think she was
also like well let's give you the story
of a lifetime
i didn't want i don't want that story
that's not the story i wanted
a little story i wanted i'm a little
sweet kyle i'm a little sweet kyle
sweetheart i gotta go back to my mom and
dad's after this
so
i gotta go back we go out there she's
like we can't go to my house because my
neighbors know what i do for a living
oh all right what the [ __ ] does that
mean
why didn't you do that with somebody
else
that means you're the neighbor's
boyfriend she's probably just a hooker
but i had to like pay
like the [ __ ] like bill was a little
bit more than she thought this month and
picked up a shift
at all stars uh so we go to daisy
and joliet and she pays yeah
she goes in she's like i'll go handle
this because they know what i do for a
living she said it twice
twice she said they know what i do for a
living at your neighbors and the people
of the days in
the days i want to know what you do for
a living
go to a day's end and it's just
we're hanging out but you don't pay
this girl also paid to take your
virginity yeah
i'm a job a great student i know i'm the
i'm the but it's also your first
ever but i'm not the john then i'm the
hooker i got pa i was paid for
yes you were bought
you were bought bro well that woman paid
to [ __ ] you
what day's in got your money what
horrible quality control on her part
probably went through at least three
quarters of a pack of her newport 100's
out of nerves did you roll your
cigarettes up in the sleep daddy i ran
out i was smoking hers
newpy 100s all right so she gets you
inside menthols she's talking is she
smoking weed or just cigarettes johnson
everything bro i just i was just sober
at that point so
sober and knowing i'm about to do a
thing i mistake that's not going to be
as cool as i think
disrobe and all right time to for sex
and it's like i'm
trying to like i'm not really attracted
to her like i was attracted the idea of
what was gonna happen but then
you know days in lighting not the
sexiest no scarves over a lamp
and uh so kind of like she's uh
you know she's uh deflating me and i'm
like at that point i'm like well i gotta
say something
dirty i'll say something uh
dirty to her i said uh oh he's uh
sucking my balls like
that i'm like is that maybe that's a
thing it's a thing yeah and
and she was like oh finally you're
participating absolutely and
just like aries
it's like it's like the when like you
see the golden retriever with the three
tennis balls it just went
just getting all the corn off the cob
right away
and and and simultaneously like
like i told you she's a long she's not a
veteran she's a veteran
the longest talent yeah uh right up
you're just
this this means [ __ ] you and it
physically
the symbolism became the realism the
symbolism went to realism
the first time you had sex she shoved
the finger up your ass you did go
pro right away i had the sex you wanted
to have i went from
when i lost my virginity i went from
exactly oh god i wanted that i went from
mall
i went from uh i went from strip mall
taekwondo to mma
in 30 seconds yeah just
[ __ ] like like how many knuckles deep
are you trying to go
is there a wrist in there at this point
and i just but did you love it
no you didn't okay why would i now
give it a [ __ ] exactly crystal might
have just warmed you up for everybody
i i remem this is where like
when do the details i remember i put my
i put my hand on her forehead and pushed
her away
and i remember i said uh that's enough
of that
i didn't know how to get out of it
because she showed no signs of stopping
and it was
uncomfortable because i didn't want to
ruin the mood
please stop right now no because i
didn't want to sound like it was bad
just take
did you come i was like oh sure oh my
god there's no way i did
then she slept she ground her teeth
she that's i just i watched the sun rise
in a [ __ ] in a a january joliet
sunrise
from a day's end room chain smoking
newport 100's
thanks to a stripper grinder i have
never slept next to you
i've never i never slept next to a woman
and so i didn't even know what grinding
teeth sounded like
and i thought like something was wrong
with the bed
because it was like she was
getting at him that hard and i just i
was like what have i done
like you get one chance and i was like
well
you gotta tell it you got into it you
didn't do this for yourself
that's a great one a
i owe you for the story a prostitute
paid to have sex with you
god bless
i even look at her that way ah [ __ ]
he's sweating now i'm sweating just
thinking about it now
oh man um
okay does crystal drive you home
crystal you're gonna spend yeah
how's that ride where was my my car was
i think my car was at my friend's house
or something she i
wasn't back to my folks house but my mom
was also like call every night even if
you're not coming home just call and let
me know so all you got to do is call
and it's like like i understand that
reasoning but like
it's like oh so she knows you're safe
but also it's a bit of a control thing
like number where you are i'm gonna know
where you're at it's like i'm an adult
but i'm also an adult that lives under
your roof not paying bills
so i can't really sit here and be like
i'm an adult because i'd be like fine
pay for your own [ __ ] i'd be like
your little boy's hungry what's in the
fridge so
i got i remember just like getting in my
car like [ __ ]
hickeys and [ __ ] and i was like ah cold
out today
when did you start with scarves like
shut the [ __ ] up man
and uh please tell me when crystal
dropped you off she peeled out
i wish please tell me i wish
no but she came back in the next night i
was working at the gas station she did
to like just hang out
all right but like she looks like being
yeah but being like
i shouldn't i feel bad like being real
trashy about it
like it's like my wallet was on the
counter she just dropped it in her pants
like hey
i like crystal i'd like crystal now
maybe maybe you weren't ready for
crystal yeah out of the gate crystal's
not what you
i don't think i said that's bodacious
the bull out
i don't think i still i'm still not
ready
[Applause]
who i am now i i think i'm glad that
maybe i'm not a person who was ever
ready for crystal
let's put it that way i think that maybe
as much as i wanted to be
bad boy cool rock and roll dude i was
just raised too
correctly to really embrace that stuff
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our next sponsor manscape support
for the honeydew and my balls is brought
to you by manscape who is the best
and men's below the waist grooming
champions of the world manscaped offers
precision
engineered tools for your family jewels
manscape just launched their fourth
generation trimmer
it's the lawnmower 4.0 you heard that
right the 4.0
join over 2 million men worldwide who
trust
manscape with this exclusive offer for
you
20 off and free worldwide shipping with
the code honeydew
at manscape.com imagine shaving with a
sleek well-designed and optimized
trimmer that makes shaving time
your favorite time in the bathroom i'm
one of the first people to try the new
4.0
and i'm blown away by the performance
the craftsmanship and details
on the 4.0 our next level all right
manscape engineered the ultimate groin
and body trimmer by focusing on
intelligent functionality
and incredibly comfortable grooming
experience their fourth generation
trimmer
features a cutting edge ceramic blade to
reduce grooming accidents thanks to
their advanced skin safe technology
i now feel confident shaving my boys
this upgraded trimmer includes a
multi-function on
off switch that can engage a travel lock
it also gives you
the ability to turn the 4000k led
spotlight
on and off when needed for a more
precise shave men
if you've been shaving with the same nut
trimmer on your face
you've been doing it wrong man no person
wants to end up with pubes in their
mouth it's time to get your own ball
hair
and body trimmer with manscape to make
me time the best time and enhance
your confidence with some nice smooth
boys your balls
will thank you get 20 off and free
shipping
with the code honeydew at manscape.com
that's 20
off with free shipping at manskate.com
and use code honeydew unlock your
confidence and always
use the right tools for the job with
manscaped
our next sponsor is purple doesn't it
seem like the world's against us from
getting a good night's sleep this time
of year i don't know about you but i got
construction out back
we got all kinds of garbage going on
right now so
when you need to have a good night's
sleep you got to get a purple mattress
you can sleep cool and comfortable no
matter what the world throws at you
that's because
only purple mattresses have the grid its
unique ventilated design
allows air to flow through to help you
sleep cool even when it feels like a
thousand degrees out and the grid
is amazingly supportive for your back
and legs while cushioning your shoulders
neck and hips all right
no matter how you sleep unlike memory
foam which remembers everything
the grid bounces back as you move and
shift so
you never get that i'm stuck feeling you
do with memory foam
all right try the purple mattress out
it's risk free
you get free shipping and returns and
financing is available too and i got the
i got one of the purple pillows and i've
never had a better
i'm a side sleeper and i'm always
bunching it up and everything this
purple pillow
lays perfectly and the last two nights
i've used it this is true
slept like a baby purple is comfort
reinvented right now
you'll get 10 off any order of 200
or more so go to purple.com honeydew use
the promo code honeydew
that's purple.com honeydew promo code
honeydew
for 10 off any order of 200
or more purple.com honeydew promo code
honeydew terms apply now let's get back
to the do
i had too much of a decent upbringing to
like
lean that way the guilt would always
bring me back to like ah
so you never had sex with her again no
and did she ever
hang out with you again after that
second time the gas would you see her at
the strip club
i do well this is the thing like okay in
the in the real talk about it
i think there probably was some trauma
because i've i've never been to therapy
so
uh i don't know where you or with
crystal because i
will say there's a lot of trauma no no
no no definitely to me
because from that yeah oh really
yeah wow for the longest time well i i i
don't know because i drink a lot but i
would never like i would never come you
know like
i would drink and hook up and would
always
couldn't finish sex for the longest time
and
to the point that i did go i went to uh
i had one
i was gail i was dating out here who
like finally got mad at me about that
happening and like was like what are you
like are you gay or something and then
realize that was a harsh thing to say
and then suggested for me to go to
like was talking to her therapist about
it and i'm like fine i'll go see
somebody but i went to like the ucla
student therapist
which they don't know [ __ ] they're still
in college yeah but i'm like i'm like i
didn't have insurance i'm like
i'm not paying full price for fake
problems to get fixed
so i went for like three weeks i went
and talked to some student who was like
a woman
was an attractive woman so that made it
hard for me to kind of discuss the
problem and i just stopped going so i
never addressed it
and for the longest time i was just
accepted like nah you're just kind of a
broken dude and whatever
like sex wasn't a priority before now
it's proven that it's not a priority i
have
happy to say since been uh the ship is
right at itself
uh which is a good thing
uh but also like i we had gone to a
strip club in the city
that'd be a few years later just a
different strip club because
after that night she came back and i
never saw her again after that and i
kind of we weren't going that much
anymore that was kind of like all right
i did the thing and i couldn't back off
from this
um but then i saw her and i think i had
like ptsd
because i saw her come out and i got
like
scared shitless i got like nervous and
sweaty and like she come over
i freaked out she's like hey and i'm
like oh [ __ ] it's like she recognized me
and i i
left yeah like i got freaked out
and again not the macho cool thing but
like yeah i think i
so there probably was some uh like
actual life
uh results and effects but that's not
fun
yeah well you know that part of the
story is not cool camaro was cool
just said shells on a motorcycle she
said like this camaro is nice she's like
yeah she's like i fix it myself i'm like
they're rough hands man i'm
knuckles man those big broken knuckles
[Music]
so anyway what other stories you want
let's hear about all right so you say
you may have had trouble so let's hear
about the first time you
actually had sex with a person where it
was mutual
like let's do this and look forward to
it
oh that would be years later i'm
guessing years
probably like a year or so yeah
that one i felt and i i felt bad about
that one because that was a girl that i
was
i was dating a girlfriend yeah yeah i
was kind of dating her
but i wasn't taking it seriously and
then
one night she wanted to have sex and it
was she was virgin
and i tried to talk her out of it
you're like listen man you want to do
this
it should be special trust me it should
be special
let me tell you now and uh and we just
we had sex
and then did you feel differently after
that
did you finally feel better like okay
this is actually something that or were
you still in there
it did but then i felt bad knowing that
i'm like oh i don't i don't plan on
seeing this person for a long time so
then i felt bad
have you ever had guilt-free sex
with strangers you mean or anyone
well that i mean with the way things are
now i mean i had i was a real
[ __ ] from 2010
2014. like i was like
now i don't think i was a creep but i
was definitely not like
like i was just half i was out having
sex yeah you were singing people yeah
i was single and maybe that's maybe it's
guilt telling me they're like look when
i'm single i'm very single when i'm not
i'm not
yeah but i hear you but it was like i'm
like oh we're hooking up and then
somebody's like well aren't we doing a
thing i'm like no i thought we were just
i thought it was two adults hooking up
and
i was misinterpreting someone else
having feelings
uh so i thought that was guilt-free
and i've been in a relationship since
2014
and so obviously that's guilt-free
um well there you go and i don't know
somebody who's understanding and it's
righted itself yeah
and like yeah some of you could talk
about your past problems and things that
are a funny story but that are kind of
maybe hiding some trauma
that you can work out with somebody they
have to get all schmaltzy but the great
thing about being with somebody that you
love and trust
is that like all right here's all the
[ __ ] that's wrong
and if you want to split i understand
but if not
i i want to work on all this stuff with
you
to uh create a good relationship yeah
and to minimize the amount of times this
[ __ ]
rears itself yeah yeah yeah like let's
like i'll just tell you why this is
happening
and what it's what past results have
been and let's get it out in the open
so yeah that's great that's that's the
spot to be
yeah that's the spot to be all right i
want to shift gears because i know you
you got to get going here in a little
bit but i want to hear about
getting pulled out of your sister's
[ __ ] house
by the police you just dropped that
nugget in there and that was this week
last week so i'm
i came down from oregon to like i'm
gonna like come back to la i bought a
van
to put my mountain bikes in and to
touring so i got a van what do you think
uh
ford transit high roof like oh yeah yeah
so i'm gonna do it i got back down to la
last friday
and my sister's in hollywood her and her
gal were out of town
so i'm at their place and uh
everything's like fine i'm getting my
favorite pizza whatever's hanging out i
had a show saturday night outdoors
got kind of ripped beers canned my ties
real shitty drinks put they will put the
screws to you
so i have these canned my ties whatever
saturday night feel like yeah back great
show fun times
sunday i wake up wicked hungover
uh and i'm just kind of just laying
around
handling [ __ ] i go take i'm trying to
clean up my mess i take the trash out
the back door their place
um now i'm laying back on the couch
just barefoot and i like this like hair
pushed back is one
but like this is this is how i'm looking
it's usually like up and all [ __ ] up
and i'm aware i know i look
you know like i look pretty homeless
and all of a sudden the
i see somebody come through the gate
into their little patio and they're
wearing masks i was weird because i
thought it was like it was my sister and
a girlfriend but like why would they be
wearing masks coming to their own home
i saw him and the door opened a little
bit their front door opened a little bit
i'm like oh maybe it's a utility
landlord called like
maintenance or something what time in a
day like 2 30 in the afternoon
and uh so i get up and i open the door
and it's just
it's like three or four cops with guns
out whoa and just
step out of the house like right away my
hands went up like
whoop and apparently i tripped off a
silent alarm
uh going out the back door apparently
it was a panic this is a thing it was a
it was a panic alarm it was the panic
alarm it was the please call the cops
right now alarm
and but i'm just like i'm barefoot
and looking like like i just found some
a hot water source
so i can't i can't come up on them about
anything
and i was like whoa that they pulled me
out
like well panic alarm was tripped
everything was
fine like they did their jobs i know
everybody has their opinion about police
right now and
i was like i put the video online and
people were like that was aggressive i'm
like
i was there it wasn't aggressive and
like
people like you [ __ ] friends of the
cop like nah i got my beef with the cops
too but
in this instance everything was
handled as it should it's because you're
[ __ ] white
alright i know that you don't have to
tell me that i've seen
what's going on but i also look like of
all the white
i'm definitely on the suspect end of
white
you're definitely honest i'm definitely
on that end
but that was your foot barefoot [ __ ]
just
bleary eye like whoa oh man
that was sunday as i'm standing outside
in the patio and they're like realizing
it's not an issue
here's three gunshots coming from like
santa monica and kawanga
and they are like can we go check that
out because that seems like it's more
important
they leave that night there's three
earthquakes
yeah i'm laying on the couch yeah i'm
laying on the couch still thinking about
how the day went down
and then [ __ ] you know god's building
inspector comes along
if i can go kick the tires out in
southern california
i go out to joshua tree because that's
what you do
i got my van stuck in the desert spent
four hours trying to dig it out before i
had i wound up with like
you know those like the big meth pickup
trucks you get to see out at the inland
empire
like they're real tall like they're just
trying to like hide from alimony
payments kind of thing
i had to get one of those dudes to come
he'd tell you
and pull me out yeah he cuz i called aaa
and they came out like
something from a disney movie bouncing
along the street like oh we can't do
this i'm like i told you what was going
on
and that's where like we just got to
call a guy like they just got a guy like
we got to call
garrett like all right come [ __ ] gary
that happened that was thursday after we
kind of camped through like a windstorm
for two days
i finally get pulled out of the desert
i come back some [ __ ] went down
friday night i did a show where they had
like physically like a heckler rushed
the stage
out in echo park at uh like uh this show
behind a barber shop
and i ran on the stage yeah i'm trying
to think like man all right
we're just getting back we're just
getting back to [ __ ] but [ __ ] have
been cooped up too they have
there's just been [ __ ] the hecklers
have been cooped up too
yeah like imagine being an isolated
[ __ ] like where do you
go you go to the comedy show first thing
and you [ __ ] up everybody's night
that was friday i got my johnson johnson
vaccine
now this is the bit i'll do the bit
johnson johnson vaccine is appropriate
name because it feels like getting
[ __ ] by two dicks at once
that took me out saturday night i was
down
so bad with chills like i'd like i think
they just gave me cove
like i don't even think it gave you a
vaccine they did no i think that gave me
the whole thing
like i think i just got the full blast
of it
that took me out saturday and yesterday
at cancel shows saturday and last night
and now i think the vaccine may i don't
want to like propagate bad information
all i know is now my like if i got
arthritis or gout i can't my knee
doesn't bend
and then some other [ __ ] happened uh
i don't know man it's been a week back
in l.a where i'm like i'm done
yeah yeah i appreciate you [ __ ] even
making time to do this for god's sake
you're in santa monica right i've flown
to china to do
shows i wouldn't come to santa monica to
do gigs when i lived here
[ __ ] people like hey i got a great
show i'm like sure man where is like
it's at the west side come on good luck
with that show good luck with that man
these traffic's not that bad these days
coming here you've got a lot
50 minutes to drive another hour and a
half to look for parking
ah [ __ ] and i was i was like i was
already late being here
and i'm like driving my knees hurt and i
find one spot i get
all the way out finally get my water my
coffee
i walk all the way around to the meter
it's out of order i'm like oh that's a
free one suck my dick no that's a free
one
really yeah yeah yeah if it's out or
you're around the park there it's not
doing me any
good now oh [ __ ] yeah i learned that
here from
the police i work with if it's out of
order you just got a free one yeah
i was wondering because i always thought
it wasn't because people back in the day
they used to take
coins and jam it in there and [ __ ] it up
but now with this digital [ __ ]
not only that these [ __ ] meters here
once the meter runs out
you can't refill it there's a weight
sensor in it
and so i thought maybe it was a
different person's car we tried
nope you got to pull off that [ __ ]
thing that's crazy
i don't know that well i didn't even
know if they're still checking stuff
because back when because we moved
out in june and i was in hollywood we
had like somebody just left their pickup
truck there
like and but it was one of those
[ __ ] park jobs was in between what
could be two spaces and finally it was
like it was stick shift so i
broke into it and popped it in neutral
and moved it myself
because i was like but yeah it was
abandoned like oh no we're not towing
any cars i'm like all right man we gotta
do some street justice i guess
i would have drifted that up to a red
curb and let them get it i was trying
like
it was i got a hill i could barely like
scoot it but it was already kinda
i didn't even break anything in the car
i actually unscrewed the latch on one of
the windows
i was impressed with myself because
again i'm a good i'm a good person yeah
you're a good kyle
well look bad boy um i appreciate you
being here
and i know we got to get you out here
but before we do i told you at the
beginning i'm going to ask you now what
advice
after everything we've talked about
would you give the 16 year old
family i think i was screaming about it
earlier i think
man just i i think
some of the stories
it's weird because advice only works
from wisdom
like you got to live to get the wisdom
so the advice is but
it's it's that with storytelling like
you can turn anything into a compelling
story
with skill so maybe you don't have to be
this life of the party and the loudest
one there and the guy who's going to do
all the crazy [ __ ]
because in retrospect when i thought i
was being the life of the party i was
just an
[ __ ] like i don't know if you have
this time like man
boy everybody thinks you're the most fun
one it's like no you're just yelling
loud enough
that you don't hear the people going
what a jag off
like yeah that's so that's great advice
maybe calm down and like
appreciate what other people are doing
instead of trying to outshine them like
it's not a competition for attention
yeah that's great i love what you're
saying right now because there is
something to be said
for the person who's present and takes
it all in and is then then the narrator
or
author of these stories later down yeah
you know and turns that
[ __ ] into something that's a that's
that's a that's very well said
you don't have to be the main character
yeah in every story you can
you can observe and collect these
stories and retell them
and it could be just as fun or
entertaining or compelling
whether or not it happened to you and i
look back at the friends like the real
artists that i was growing up with were
the ones that kind of still
were mentally documenting what was
happening we're around for it
but weren't trying to make the headline
out of it you know that's great
um well thank you for coming on here
this was a lot of fun we got in there it
was a lot of fun we didn't even talk
about time you almost quit comedy
because of that chick
was it crystal girl that was a whole
different girl
um one more time plug whatever you want
promote whatever you'd like
just kyle kanan on all the platforms i
don't really only mess with instagram
now and even that not a fan of being on
there i hear you
i'm out there just look it up i put an
album out last year i think it flopped
so check that out it's my my most proud
thing i've put out in comedy and it [ __ ]
the bed so uh go check that out
i think it's on spotify maybe this is
why it flopped because i don't know how
to promote things i i think it's on
spotify
go listen to 100 times so i can get a
cup of coffee there you go
uh well as always ryan sickler on all
social media ryan sickler.com we'll talk
to you all
next week
[Music]
you